how's it going everyone my name is
Pierre ba and welcome to Friday's with
BA
okay that was pretty dumb dumb title but
I thought I'll do this blog if sort of
things at least once a week and it's a
way for me to get closer to you guys cuz
I've been growing a lot on YouTube
lately and it's a it's great of course
but it's also shameful because I can't
really communicate that the same thing
that I used to be I used to have be able
to have a conversation with my fans and
all that but I just it's impossible it's
just like too many people right now and
I know some of you get offended if I
don't answer you and I just want to say
please don't be offended there's a lot
of people riding through me and like
steam for example like every time I go
on steam is like I mean it's great and
I'd love to talk to you but it's I just
don't have time I'm sorry
so just don't get me wrong I really do
love talking with you guys and that's
why I'm doing this so maybe I can I
don't know I can do pretty much anything
if you have any suggestion then leave it
down below but the next week I am doing
a Q&A cuz it's been like forever since I
did one and I thought it could be cool
and I'll read your question if you leave
it in the comment section
and I think that was it did I mention
did i mention about t-shirts I think I'm
working on some t-shirts and I have some
other artists working on them for me as
well
it's gonna be great I'm really excited
about it I'm it's a shame I can't
announce it today maybe next week I'll
wear one and announce it hopefully and
that's a pretty cool way to support me
and get a cold teacher but anyway I'll
announce that in time thank you for
25,000 subscribers I have more good news
coming up but I can't really talk about
it right now so I'm gonna end it here
and just say have a good weekend and
I'll see you pretty soon
[Music]